الحرب على منصات السوشيال ميديا في ليبيا
عنوانها محل العاب ليبيا تويز والسبب هو
فيديو 8 نشره على صفحه المحل مؤخرا لمدير
الشركه وهو بيوضح موظفه والسبب صانعه
محتوى
وشباب الاداره معنا خاصه
بناء
الفاضله
بشكل كويس عنده متابعه مشهوره
بشكل كويس
ان الخطا صار من اهل الموظفين واعطي نعتذر
عليه بشكل رسمي ك- طريق عمل داخل جناتا
خطر من الموظف احنا كنا في بنعرف ان
الموظفين ما يستقروش ما يقعدوا في اعمالهم
كل مره بنتكلم كل مره يجيب موظف لكن
حاولوا احنا شركه نجيبه احسن الموظفين
القصه المتداوله انه في مشهوره من صانعي
المحتوى اللي بيختص بالطبخ في ليبيا اسمها
منى معتوق نشرت ستوري على احد حساباتها
انه اشترت لعبه لابنتها من محل الليبيا
تويز فرع زناته لكن تم معاملتها بشكل غير
جيد من قبل احد الموظفين اللي ما يعرفها
ومن بعدها ما شفنا المحل الا من نزل كده
فيديو او شفنا هذا الفيديو اللي انتم
شفتوه حضرتكم الان بعنوان زياره رئيس مجلس
الاداره والمدير العام واعضاء مجلس
الاداره وفي بيظهر المدير جامعه الموظفين
وبيدخل معنا بسبب الشكوى ويبدو كانوا
فاكرين في الاداره انه كده هيحلوا الازمه
لكن هو مشعللوها وزعله الناس عليهم طبعا
نعتبروهم يعني انه اللي سووه هذا توبيخ
الموظفين اعتبروها اهانه وغير مقبول يعني
من بعد رده الفعل السلبيه وضجه هذه طلعت
صانعه المحتوى وانا معتوب توضح وكتبت على
صفحتها انه هي ما قدمت شكوى ولا كلمت احد
ولا شيء وان هي بس قالت في الستوري على
سناب انه صار معاها موقف مو حلو معاهم
وانه الشركه من نفسها اتصلت عليها واعتذرت
منها وقالت كمان انه الكلام اللي انتشر
على انها راحه المحل وعرفت عن حالها وما
عرفوها وعلشان كده اشتكتهم قالت ان هذا
الكلام غير صحيح قالت كمان ان ما تقبل
اهانه اي شخص امامها وطلبت من الشركه انها
تبري ذمتها وتشرح ان الفيديو ما كان بيطلب
منه وهي مالها دخل وقالت انه الشركه اكدت
لها اصلا انه ما احد انفصل من شغله ومن
بعد ما طلع زوجها كمان انه شربوست قال في
انه اللي صار عيب انه زوجته محتواها طبخ
امور نسائيه وما بتتعامل مع احد وحتى
صورها ما بتنزلها وانه زوجته ما قدمت شكوى
ابدا وهم ما بيقبلوا مين هان اي شخص ولا
يقطعه برزق احد وطلب من الناس انه يتوقفوا
عن تداول اسم زوجته في اللي صار فيعني
فيلم طويل عريض والسبب مدير حب يكحلها
فراح عمها من صاحب الشركه ومديره طلع
بعدين اعتذر من الموظفين والناس واعتبر
اللي صار سوء
يا ايها الذين امنوا ان جاءكم فاسق بنبا
فتبينوا اخوتي اللي بين اليوم خاطب فيكم
كصاحب شركه او صاحب ليبيا تويز اعتقد الي
صار لنا اليوم على السوشيال ميديا امانه
شيء كبير وصارت مشكله كبيره اول شيء يعني
نعتذر من سوء الفهم اللي صار للجميع
اعتذر من الجميع
واصدقائي واليوم معي فتره طويله وسنوات
طويله يشتغلوا معي سواء زباينه واللي
فهموا الموضوع غلط يعني اليوم فيديو
نقلوه عده
بطريقه ما هي مش مضبوطه همم فسبب ضجه
كبيره
صاحب ومدير الشركه في الفيديو كمان شكر
كمان السلطات على التدخلها لحمايه
الموظفين لانه على فكره تدخلت وزاره العمل
والتاهيل وعمل الجوله التفتيش على محلات
في الواقعه واكدت انه تم فتح تحقيق
باليسار وراح يتم اتخاذ الاجراءات
القانونيه اللازمه وف قانون العمل
[موسيقى]